أو نيلسون مانديلا كانوا يشاهدونه
طوال اليوم ، هل تريد أن ترى شيئًا
لتقول كم نشعر بهذه الخسارة الفادحة ، كان
العالم كله يميل جانبًا في
رحيله ، وكان شرف قضاء
بضع دقائق معه قبل أن يصبح
رئيسًا في الواقع.  كان يقرأ في
اليوم الذي أعلن فيه أنه سيبتهج
لأنك تحل ذلك بدوره مني
لكنه كان ينزع سلاحه وكان
مضحكًا جدًا عندما سمعناه وجعل
حياته كثيرًا وكنت فخورة جدًا لأنني
كنت  بضع دقائق
لكنه سيعيش في قلوبنا
إلى الأبد ، هل يمكنك أن تخبرنا أن هناك
أي فيلم تخطط لمشاهدته
هنا أو حسنًا لم أشاهد جدول
الأعمال وكان فلسطينيًا مدعوًا
لمشاهدته على الفور على ما أعتقد  ما
هي الانطباعات التي تتوقعها من
مهرجان الأفلام الأجنبية هنا في الشرق
الأوسط ، كما تعلم ، لقد جئت مع
الترقب لاستكشاف هذه المنطقة
لأنني لم أذهب إلى هنا من قبل قبل أن
أكون من سوريا
قبل موقع النظام الملكي ،
لذلك لا أعرف  ريجي  لا
أعرف ما الذي أتوقعه ولكني متحمس جدًا
لوجودي هنا وهو
نوع من أن أكون جزءًا مما يحدث ،
لا أنا على حق ، فليس كل شخص قد خلق
الكثير من عمري في نفس الوقت  أنا
فخور جدًا لوجودي هنا مع
توقعاتك بالتمثيل وماذا
تنصح صانعي الأفلام وصانعي
الأفلام الشباب والممثلين الذين حصلوا عليه في كل
مكان ، فأنت تعرف صناعة السينما
أن الفنانين الشباب الذين يأتون
الآن أو مذهلين  لم يكن لدي
أي دليل على أن التقدم الذي أحرزناه في
حياتي لم نعد نستخدم الفيلم بعد الآن
للعمل الصوتي الرقمي ، نعم ، لديهم
كل التكنولوجيا بالطريقة التي
كانوا عليها في أنفسهم فأس أنا  مدهش
مع ما يفعله صانعو الأفلام هذه
الأيام ، ولا سيما الشباب ،
فهم ليسوا من
التقاليد العالية التي تعرف أنهم
أحرار والأفلام حقًا دولية